so anyway years later met for as a hobby
actually john danaher um i met john
danaher and he put me in touch with for
as a hobby
i started training at tristar i you know
immediately loved uh working with frost
and learning under for us started
training at tristar and i did my first
real professional mma fight
um as someone that actually does had
practiced a little bit
in i think august 2012 um
and uh that was against a guy he was
four and five at the time so
you know had some experience um good
kind of like first go for me honestly
and i won that fight by tko
and then it was a little bit of a time
off and then i did another fight against
a tough guy named uh magic hammer um he
was five and two at the time i think he
was three and i was amazed you know good
good little bit of fighting experience
um won that one in the first round
uh via rear naked choke and then uh
started to experience difficulty getting
getting fights
at that point um you know you
continuously introduced as like the
the master of grappling the submission
at least that would that was my thing if
i don't know if i was
that was the source of the fear for
people i think so because i mean that
definitely wasn't
much at striking at that point you know
i definitely am a lot
i'd like to think i'm pretty hard to
hurt although i try not to lean on that
and i
played baseball for like 16 years so i
can hit things pretty hard i just
wasn't able to uh i i recognized pretty
early on that i had no idea how to
actually hit things
hard without becoming hittable myself so
i think that's kind of the big thing is
a lot of times like we almost
were mentioning uh before if you try to
go and get people
too early you can hit them if they're
not that good but you're going to get
hit yourself so you're making you're
basically making a wager you're making a
trade of your own life
for the ability to hit them when you
watch guys like israel lot of sonia
floyd mayweather stephen thompson
uh conor mcgregor when he's fighting
really well it's not a trade
they're not you're hitting them and
they're hitting you it's they're hitting
you
but it takes years and years and years
and years to be able to learn how to do
that ton lee is another great example of
that and you know my closest training
partner one of my best friends
and uh currently now uh one champion uh
with one championship in uh in asia the
champion of the
featherweight or i guess lightweight
featherweight um 155
over there now and he recently defeated
martin nguyen in a really great fight
and
tom knocked him out longtime champion
and ton doesn't let you hit him he
doesn't let you touch him i feel so
fortunate to have met guys like steven
and ton
to go early on in career and go holy
moly
i can't even it's not even like oh
you'll let me walk over and find you
it's like fighting a ghost that
periodically shows up with a hammer and
smokes you in the melon and then
disappears into the ether again
so the way they approach the fighting
game is thinking how can i attack
without being hit
because every every strategy every idea
you have about what you're going to do
has to do with uh like that uh
minimizing the the return yeah abs
absolutely i mean that's what all good
fighting has done all poor fighting if
you know throughout the course of
history most generals whether they saw a
read or
you know they they did battles by
attrition yeah you know it's like yeah
man i've got 150 guys you've got 50 like
yeah
60 of my guys die killing your 50 like
that's great for me yeah but uh that's
not so great for the 60 guys that died
you know
i hope it's worth it so when you realize
that not only you're not just
kobe bryant and you're phil jackson too
you got to do everything
you know if you've got to run across the
beach at normandy so be it but that
better be
you should have make sure we thought
this through and there's like hey
there's no way we can like
you know walk around the side huh
because oftentimes there there is and i
i think a lot of times there's a lot of
incentives in professional fighting to
for people who want to do that and we
come up with all sorts of well i'm
trying to be exciting
are you is that really what you came
here to do because i came here to win
and i think that anyone that that's
really successful came there to win and
if it ends up being exciting well that's
fantastic i hope that people enjoy
watching something and that's great but
that's a qualitative assessment anyway
you know you want to also be able to
you know live the rest of your life i
think it's easy you know i'll
use meldrick taylor i'm a big boxing fan
elder taylor was an excellent fighter
um came this close uh to a world title
and was stopped with like
he was in a fight that he was winning
with seconds remaining literally seconds
remaining and they probably could have
just let it go and he would have been
world champion and
it was brutal if you ever watch
legendary nights like uh hbo boxing show
it's it's great
but uh it's heartbreaking it's
absolutely heartbreaking and also like
the beating that he absorbed in that
fight changed him for the rest of his
life
and also you know don't think he'd never
been hit before but it was one of those
where you go
it's it's all fun and games until you
can't remember your name at age 44 years
old
and i didn't come here what are they
what did patton saying nobody nobody
wins the war by dying for his country
make the other poor bastard die for his
and uh i think that that's kind of what
we're shooting for
and you know the lionization of
absorbing damage and that not being a
big deal like you hear that all the time
so and so can take
shots that would put a lesser fighter
down
what does that even mean yeah you know
like still make it this straight your
ability to absorb damage
is a part of you i mean i guess that
don't get me wrong that is an attribute
that's nice to have if you
if you need it but there's plenty of
people that actually have really porous
defense
that are just very very difficult to
hurt for whatever reason
that's a fascinating fighter's
perspective on the thing i mean the
the the story that is
inspiring and i know it goes against
the artistry of fighting is when you
have taken the damage
to still rise up and be able to defeat
the opponent
so it's uh but that
that's the flip side of a basically you
failing to defend yourself properly
right
i agree but let's say for i think it's
it's a time that's a triumph of
of humanity that's triumph that's
amazing to witness such a thing is
unbelievable
but you still go this is there is a cost
here it's like i
i've been fortunate enough to spend some
time working with with the military and
i've been like around and read medal of
honor citations they're unbelievable
like you read the story and you think
it it's it'll floor you but it's all a
cost and you don't want to be paying
that cost
and most of the time with the cost was
everything and then sometimes you go hey
yeah
the value here it's worth everything
it's like i defend your family
you defend your country under certain
circumstances and at that point it's
extension of your family
you're like hey this is worth it to
casually throw your life away or throw
your huffle it's foolish there's nothing
there's nothing
great about that and like you said it's
still an amazing thing to see
but but it's also amazing to see you not
take damages to floyd mayweather it's
the artistry of like not being hit and i
wonder if maybe that's why people don't
resonate with floyd as much as obviously
muhammad ali was such a time and place
a great man for so many different
reasons although it was funny to
remember like
there were times when he wasn't very
popular we love him now because of time
of context
you know time to move away from some of
the nonsense he had to deal with
but uh we got to see him struggle and
also he had unbelievable sacrifice both
in and out of the ring
you know that that we all got to witness
we've never really seen floyd struggle
like that and granted obviously floyd
isn't like a civil rights figure like
muhammad ali was it's different time
different place and he's a different man
but basically uh
you know i wonder if part of the thing
that made us that made everyone think of
muhammad
ali as the greatest in addition to of
course the unbelievable things that he
did out in the world
um and the stands that he made we saw
him struggle in the ring
it's it's almost it's humanizing you
know it's it's weird when
people yeah people respect b but again
it's we saw
gsp lose and gsp came back stronger
khabib is
amazing but i wonder i wonder how people
feel about him long term not like they
won't think of him as amazing and great
and he's been a respectable person and
champion but uh
the time he hasn't he hasn't had to fall
yeah if that makes sense and also
coupled with uh ali had a
a way of being poetic
about sort of the way he was in the ring
sort of being able to explain the
artistry that he i mean
there's like joking as being playful but
really he was
able to describe the the flow like a
butterfly's thing like could be like he
was able to
actually talk about his strategy without
talking
without crossing that line into the
floyd mayweather when you're just
talking about money and and just talking
that's true
actually conor mcgregor when he's not
talking is pretty good at like
talking about the art of the marshall
and like the first okay and uh i wish
khabib did the same
actually uh from uh
like the satya brothers there's a few
there's a culture of like being poetic
about like being scholars
and also uh bards or whatever the poets
of the game
and khabib was more like just simple
and he lets his actions speak which is
is great too
in his own way yeah it's great but it's
nice when you can tell stories
and you know that that's probably why
ali was the great
you